salut aujourd'hui je vous donne une
nouvelle énigme et juste avant je vous
donne la solution à l'énigme d'hier si
vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo d'hier
allait la voir pour voir l'énigme
d'abord avant d'écouter la réponse la
réponse et la lettre n tout simplement
la lettre n
parce que n c'est bien la lettre qui
commence le mot nuit c'est bien la
lettre qui finit le mot matin et on
trouve deux fois la lettre n dans le mot
année c'était un peu une énigme en mode
les chiffres et les lettres
je pense que vous êtes nombreux à
l'avoir trouvé je le regardais le quota
de pouce en l'air par rapport aux
nombres de vue mais je pense que vous
êtes nombreux et c'est pour ça qu'on
passe tout de suite à la prochaine et
digne les quatre dernière énigme on est
sur les quatre dernière énigme de cette
série de l'été et on reprend la chaîne
avec le calendrier habituel dans cinq
jours
cette énigme 29 est une énigme
différentes je m'en suis rappelé très
très très récemment quand j'ai écrit
toutes ces énigmes là c'est une énigme
qu'on m'a fait quand j'étais en colo
quand j'étais petit je devais avoir
entre six et huit ans m a fait galérer
durant des jours et des jours pour
trouver je comprenais pas je vous la
fais touche touche pas touche pas touche
donc qu'est-ce qui touche et pourquoi la
question c'est bien qu est-ce qui touche
et pourquoi donc vouloir en fait touche
touche pas touche pas touche qu est-ce
qui touche et pourquoi en indice
pourrait aller plus loin en vous disant
que pourquoi touche
pourquoi touche mentale touche vlok
touche pas donc qu'est-ce qui touche et
pourquoi ai je me souviens que ceux qui
m'ont fait les nuits me faisait tourner
en bourrique à me donner des nouveaux
mots à m'expliquer que que canapés sa
touche alors que fenêtre ça touche pas
quand je vais vous donner la réponse
demain vous allez le faire à tout le
monde et vous allez voir c'est vraiment
très drôle à faire mais peut-être que
vous connaissez ou encore mieux que vous
allez trouver la réponse dans ce cas là
ne lui dit pas dans les commentaires
pour laisser les autres se chercher mais
vous le savez laisser un pouce en l'air
qui nous sert pour cette série d'énigmes
de compteurs pour compter le nombre de
personnes qui trouve la bonne réponse
profitez encore du soleil demain c'est
le week-end donc je suis sûr que vous
allez kiffer n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner avant de partir et rendez vous
demain à 11 heures puisque le week-end
c'est 11h ciao
oui